ALREADY MORE THAN ALL OF 2019.
THE HEAD OF MEXICO'S REFUGEE
COMMISSION SAYS BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER, THAT NUMBER WILL BE
CLOSE TO 90,000.
NEARLY 71% OF THOSE MIGRANTS
PASSED THROUGH TAPACHULA.
AND SOME HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING TO
YOU WILL HELP US BECAUSE
EVERYBODY HERE WANT TO HAVE A
BETTER LIFE AND A FUTURE.
WANT TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE
TOMORROW, WANT TO WORK.
>> Griff: WILL DID YOU GO BACK
TO HAITI.
>> NO, NO.
NEVER, NEVER.
>> Griff: HOWEVER, NOT ALL FROM
HAITI.
MANY ARE FROM THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE OF HONDURAS, GUATEMALA
AND EL SALVADOR AND SOME AS FAR
AS GHANA.
>> BIDEN, HELP US OR WE WILL
DIE.
>> BECOME VERY DIFFICULT FOR US
AND WE HAVE CHILDREN.
WE ARE SICK AND WE NEED TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL.
>> Griff: PART OF A PIPELINE OF
MIGRANTS RUNNING FROM SOUTH
AMERICA THROUGH THIS SOUTHERN
MEXICAN TOWN AND EVENTUALLY THE
U.S. BORDER.
>> I WANT TO GO TO THE UNITED
STATES WITH MY FAMILY.
ALL THE PEOPLE HERE IN MEXICO
WANT TO DO THAT.
TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE.
>> Griff: BRET, MEXICAN
OFFICIALS HERE IN CHARGE OF
REFUGEES IN THE STATE OF IT SAY
THEY ARE PREPARING FOR AN
ONSLAUGHT OF AS MANY AS 15,000
CONFIRMED MIGRANTS IN SOUTH
AMERICA, MANY HAITIAN, MANY IN
COLOMBIA ON THEIR WAY HERE.
SO MUCH SO THAT OFFICIALS
TOMORROW MORNING ARE OWNING UP A
SOCCER STADIUM TO DEAL WITH THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBERS.
BRET?
>>